yo I saw uh when the shooting happened
in Buffalo
um I saw you had said that uh when you
were growing up you worked at not that
same location yeah but you worked at a
different one of those girls yeah yeah
that was obviously an extremely
um I was a pretty crazy day yeah
um were you in town when that happened
no but my mom well first my grandmother
had called me I was getting on a plane I
actually was on my way to a show because
this was during like the Griselda tour
right
um and my grandmother called me and was
like Hey can you turn on those because
you don't she like stupid she don't do
no internet she don't do anything
she was like yo
um I heard that it was a shooting or
something at a grocery store can you
look it up so then I looked it up and I
seen that it was at tops and this tops
is around the corner from where like my
mom lives at wow so like and then I
called my mom and just check on her
because she goes there all the time and
my mom was like hysterical and crying
and she was like I was on my way there
and this time the third it was just it
was a lot yeah now that [ __ ] was
terrible your mom was on the way there
Jesus yeah and it's not like again you
can get anywhere in Buffalo 10 to 15
minutes so just imagine like you live
around a corner you right there and then
you're seeing all these cop cars and it
was crazy it was bodies out there it was
just wow yeah Buffalo is a place that
like I went like I said I went there for
a couple of days and I really I really
liked it like I really thought Buffalo
was like a Vibe and I didn't know what
to expect going there but it was very uh
it wasn't as cold as I uh thought it was
going to be as we discussed the food was
solid but it just fell felt like its own
like I've been to Detroit before and
I've heard people compared to troying
Buffalo but I just felt like its own
thing like what part of Buffalo are you
from I'm from the east side of Buffalo
like I grew up in a fruit belt and you
know I stayed like
uh like in the east side like they call
it Bucktown Cold Springs I stayed in the
area nice